ich habe über 200 000 € in eine Idee
investiert ohne zu wissen ob daraus
tatsächlich etwas werden kann und auf
diesem Weg nehme ich euch mit viel Spaß
mit Startup Folge 2 in der letzten Folge
haben wir gelernt dass Startups nicht
gleich Startups sind und ich zwar die
Reichweite für consumbls wie Chips
Energy Drinks oder Pizza hätte aber kein
Produkt so wirklich verkörpere alles
schön und gut aber wie gründet man denn
jetzt wirklich ein Unternehmen wie viel
Kohle braucht man dafür woher kommt
diese Kohle und was zur Hölle ist meine
Idee als allererstes brauchte ich
Partner die mehr von der tatsächlichen
umsetz und dem technischen Bereich
verstehen glücklicherweise kam am Ende
der letzten Folge ja diese Mail im
Prinzip stand sowas in der Mail wie hey
wir sind drei Jungs die an der App
arbeiten und suchen einen Creator der
bereit wäre Werbung für uns zu machen
Problem wir haben keine Kohle und
arbeiten alle Vollzeit nebenbei und
anstatt Werbung zu machen habe ich die
Jungs angerufen und von meiner Idee
erzählt relativ schnell haben wir
gemerkt dass meine Idee und ihre schon
programmierte Basis ziemlich gut
zusammen funktionieren könnten und jetzt
könnte man 32 Mails von A nach B
schicken PowerPoint Präsentationen
austauschen mehrere Zoom calls machen
aber anstatt das alles zu tun haben die
Jungs ihr Auto gepackt und waren keine
48 Stunden nach dem Absenden der ersten
Mail das erste mal hier in Köln in
meinem Büro in einem 12 Stunden Termin
haben wir uns dann das erste Mal
persönlich kennengelernt und
gleichzeitig die Idee weitergesponnen
über Themen nachgedacht sie wieder
verworfen um am Ende zu merken dass
meine Idee mit ihrer schon
programmierten Basis eine unheimlich
krasse Kombination sein könnte ihr könnt
mir glauben die Tage sind super
anstrengend nicht nur für den Kopf
sondern auch für den Körper und ich
benutze jede freie Minute vor und nach
dem Treffen um irgendwie an der Idee zu
arbeiten und bei so einer anstrengenden
Zeit verabschiedet sich als erstes mein
Schlafrhythmus und kurz danach das
Gefühl rechtzeitig was essen zu müssen
und damit das nicht mehr passiert
unterstützt mich Jul der Partner des
heutigen Videos die Trinkmahlzeiten von
Jul sind genau das was ich in diesen
Momenten brauche kein fettiges Fastfood
das mich müde langsam und träge macht
kein Essen bestellen und auf Essen
warten sondern eine einfache und
schnelle Möglichkeit um mich sofort in
den Moment mit allen wichtigen
Nährstoffen zu versorgen echte
pflanzliche Zutaten 26 Vitamine und
Mineralien wenig Zucker viel Protein all
in eine ausgewogene Mahlzeit in der
Flasche die fast so schmeckt wie ein
Milkshake das Beste ist man trinkt sich
nie an einer Sorte satt mit vielen
verschiedenen Geschmacksrichtungen im
rregal hat man immer die freie Auswahl
was gerade am besten passt das Ding ist
bei mir passiert wirklich nicht selten
dass ich den ganzen Tag keine Zeit fürs
Essen habe bzw mir nicht vernünftig Zeit
fürs Essen nehme weil ich irgendwie ein
Telefonaten sitze am Autofahren bin oder
vor der Kamera stehe und da ist das die
perfekte Lösung die plantbase trink
Malzeiten von H schmecken top mein
Favorite IC Caramel coffee super
praktisch für unterwegs und durch ohne
dabei Abstriche zu machen Check bei euch
im RO um die Ecke gibt's quasi überall
probiert das selber mal aus vielen Dank
an Hul fürs möglich machen für mehr
Infos Check den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung und jetzt viel Spaß
weiter mit dem Video zwei Tage nach dem
ersten Termin haben alle drei ihre gut
bezahlten Jobs bei renommierten großen
deutschen Unternehmen gekündigt um
gemeinsam mit mir gründen zu können ich
habe mich darauf kommittet mein gesamtes
Erspartes bzw sogar noch ein bisschen
mehr als ich zu dem Zeitpunkt überhaupt
auf dem Konto hatte nämlich 200.000 € in
die Idee zu investieren bedeutet all Inf
von mir und allin von den Jungs und
damit stand das Gründerteam aus vier
Personen fest ich bin der Matthias bin
ich Entwickler zuständig fürs Backend
ich bin Tilmann bin verantwortlich dafür
dass das Produkt gebaut wird zusätzlich
mache ich auch noch die Entwicklung
davon im Frontend ich bin der Dominik im
Endeffekt bin ich alles was nicht Spaß
macht die Administration
buchhaltungstechnische Sache aber auch
das wichtige muss auch irgendwie
verkauft werden und da bin ich für die
Ansprache für die Brands zuständig und
mache eben alles was mit partnerships
etc zu tun hat esamt muss man aber sagen
jeder macht deutlich mehr als man in dem
konventionellen Job in diese
Jobbezeichnung packen würde und das ist
in dem Startup völlig normal es gibt
einfach viel zu viel zu tun und viel zu
wenig Manpower seid Ihr also jemand mit
Erfahrung in egal welchem Bereich der
uns helfen könnte sales code was auch
immer dann bewerbt euch über den Link in
der Videobeschreibung wenn ihr Bock auf
eine richtig krasse neue Aufgabe habt
mit einem Team von insgesamt vier
Gründern und den ersten zwei
Angestellten geht die Reise von jetzt an
also los doch bevor wir auch nur ein
Cent mit einer Firma verdienen können
müssen wir erstmal eine Firma gründen
und auch hier
damit ist die Firma gegründet gibt es
riesige Unterschiede denn es gibt eine
Menge verschiedene Geschäftsformen die
alle ihre Vor und Nachteile haben den
meisten Plan davon haben Anwälte und
Steuerberater jeder von uns hat schon
mal GmbH GbR oder AG gehört klingt immer
wichtig aber so wirklich wissen was das
ist tun die wenigsten im Prinzip
unterscheidet man Unternehmen in drei
Kategorien Einzelunternehmen
Personengesellschaften und
Kapitalgesellschaften solltest Du wie
ich Youtuber werden wollen und einfach
ein paar Videos produzieren das alleine
bist du als Einzelunternehmer oder frei
wahrscheinlich ziemlich gut beraten das
bringt aber auch riesige Nachteile mit
wie z.B Haftung du haftest nämlich mit
allem auch dem was du privat besitzt
sollte die Idee also über dir
zusammenbrechen könnte es sein dass
irgendwann an deiner Tür klingelt und
z.B dein Fernseher gefendelt wird
erstens bin ich in dieser Idee nicht
alleine und zweitens wollen wir unseren
Fernseher behalten also fällt das schon
mal raus Option 2 sind
Personengesellschaften die sind im
Prinzip das gleiche nur dass sie von
mindestens zwei Personen gegründet
werden aber auch in diesem Fall gibt es
dasselbe Problem auch hier haften wir
wieder uneingeschränkt sprich mit allem
was wir haben bleiben noch
Kapitalgesellschaften wie ist der Name
schon verrät steht hier nicht die Person
im Vordergrund sondern das Kapital das
hat den Vorteil dass wir nur mit unserem
geschäftsvermögenhaften und nicht mit
unserem Privatvermögen natürlich noch
eine Menge andere Vorteile aber das ist
einer der größten Unterschied bei den
wichtigsten kapitalgesellschaften sind
GmbH und Aktiengesellschaft wir sind
aber noch kein Konzern und wir wollen
unsere Anteile zumindest noch nicht
kleinteilig verkaufen und am Ende bleibt
die GmbH vermutlich die bekannteste
Gesellschaftsform überhaupt alles was du
für die Gründung brauchst sind 25000 €
mit den du dann haftest we das für uns
aber am besten passt haben wir das in
Kauf genommen und uns am Ende für die
Gründung einer GmbH entschieden und
unsere Anteile an der Firma nicht privat
zu besitzen sondern jeweils noch eine
weitere GmbH zu gründen welche den
einzigen Sinn und Zweck verfolgt unsere
Unternehmensanteile zu verwalten ich
persönlich besitze also Anteile an einer
GmbH die wiederum Anteile an einer GmbH
besitzt das ganze nennt man holding und
ist so ziemlich der Standardweg für so
eine Gründung nach viel hin und her mit
anwäten hatten wir dann einen Vertrag
der für uns alle gepasst hat und konnten
uns endlich um einen Notartermin kümmern
heute wird es offiziell wir sind beim
Notar moin moin Was geht ab heute ist
auch wenn in den letzten Monaten schon
einiges passiert ist ist heute der
offizielle Start also der wirklich
offizielle Start in dem wir
beurkunden dass wir gemeinsam die Firma
so machen wollen wie wir sie machen dass
ich mich verpflichte das Geld zu
investieren dass ich investieren möchte
und dann die Firma ab heute wirklich
startet also ab heute wird's ernst die
Firma ist also gegründet ich habe
unheimlich starke Gesellschafter an
meiner Seite und wir haben durch mein
Investment erstmal genug Startkapital um
loslegen zu könen und deswegen endlich
zur Erklärung was unsere Idee ist und
wieso affiliate Marketing ist ein
Riesending im Internet ein Nutzer kommt
über den Link eines Affiliate marketers
in einen Shop kauft dort etwas ein und
der Affiliate Marketer erhält weil er
den Nutzer in den Shop gebracht hat
anteilig etwas vom Umsatz dieses System
ist aber in den meisten Fällen für
Creator und für Nutzer unbrauchbar klar
es gibt Amazon Affiliate das Creator
eine einfache Möglichkeit gibt vonili zu
profitieren aber die meisten wirklich
großen Umsätze werden eben in anderen
Shops gemacht niemand kauft seine Möbel
für eine neue Wohnung bei Amazon niemand
Bucht seinen Jahresurlaub bei Amazon
niemand kauft seinen neuen Gaming PC bei
Amazon und niemand bestellt jeden Abend
seine Pizza über Amazon das ist einfach
so die Liste geht noch ewig weiter aber
ich glaube ihr habt's verstanden der
Creator müsste sich bei jedem einzelnen
onlineeshop ein Affiliate Zugang
beschaffen und diesen einzelnen bewerben
das wäre bei tausenden onlineeshops viel
zu aufwendig und viel zu wenig
und außerdem was hat die Community davon
den Link des creators zu nutzen richtig
gar nichts und hier kommen wir ins Spiel
wir bauen eine App in der alle wichtigen
onlineeshops gelistet sind Creator
bekommen einen personalisierten Creator
Code den die Community in unserer App
auswählen kann was zur Folge hat dass
der Creator an den Einkäufen der
Community mitverdient und der Kunde zum
ersten Mal die Möglichkeit hat auch
etwas dafür zu bekommen den Creator Code
oder den Affiliate Link seines creators
zu benutzen und zwar nicht irgendwas zu
bekommen sondern den absoluten
Bärenanteil 80% der a gezahlten
Provisionen bekommt nämlich der Nutzer
also die Person aus der Community und
20% der verbleibenden Provisionen gehen
an den Creator wir als App nehmen uns
zum Start erstmal gar nichts Beispiel
ihr öffnet über unsere App ein
reisebuchungsportal und bucht einen
Sommerurlaub für 1000 € es gibt 5%
Cashback in diesem reisebuchungsportal
bedeutet ihr bekommt 50 € für die
Buchung über unsere App zurück 10 €
gehen an die Person dessen Creator Code
ausgewählt habt die euch quasi in unsere
App geführt hat natürlich geht das noch
deutlich weiter ihr kauft Weihnachts
Geschenke für Freunde und Familie ihr
bestellt jeden Abend essen bei
Lieferando es gibt im Prinzip auf fast
alles Cashback bei uns richtig
interessant wir gleich wenn ich euch von
den noch kommenden Funktionalitäten
erkläre aber stellt es euch erstmal vor
wie einen Fortnite Creator Code auf
Steroiden auch ein Support Creator Code
Kuss ein Code den ihr nicht nur im appic
Store benutzen könnt sondern in
hunderten onlineeshops quasi überall wo
ihr shoppen wollt bei dem ihr den
Bärenanteil dafür bekommt diesen Code
tatsächlich zu nutzen bist du also
Creator dann klick auf den Link in der
Videobeschreibung und mach dir einen
Account um deinen Creator Code und
Zugriff aufs creator Dashboard zu
erhalten das ist wie YouTube Studio da
siehst du alle Stats und so weiter auch
wenn du dir noch unsicher bist ob du den
Creator Code am Ende wirklich benutzen
willst mach dir lieber ein Account weil
wir nicht garantieren können jeden
freizuschalten gerade desto näher wir an
den Release kommen der nur noch 7 Tage
entfernt ist weil wir in Startup sind
und wir uns natürlich auf die Anwendung
für den Nutzer fokussieren ist der
Creator Link bisher nur über Desktop zu
erreichen also macht den Account am PC
in den letzten Monaten ist mir
aufgefallen dass YouTube und allgemein
Social Media sich extrem schnell
internationalisiert konkret bedeutet das
YouTube veröffentlicht multilanguage
Audio und eine Menge Youtuber
veröffentlichen mittlerweile ihre Videos
in unheimlich vielen Sprachen bedeutet
Content der früher nur für eine deutsche
oder nur für eine englische Zielgruppe
verfügbar war ist mittlerweile in vielen
Fällen für die ganze Welt und quasi alle
Sprachen verfügbar was mega cool ist
gleichzeitig gibt es dadurch aber auch
ein riesenprem und zwar Werbung die
essentiell für Creator ist um den ganzen
Spaß zu finanzieren und die einzige
Möglichkeit Videos kostenlos zur
Verfügung zu stellen ist häufig noch
nicht international nehmen wir Mr Beast
als beis bepiel seine Videos werden
mittlerweile in all diesen Sprachen
veröffentlicht womit er fast die ganze
Welt abdeckt es gibt aber nur extrem
wenige Firmen die ein Produkt haben dass
sie international bewerben können
geschweige denn internationale Budgets
für Youtube Werbung locker machen die
meisten Werbetreibenden werben
spezifisch in verschiedenen Regionen was
komplett Sinn macht eigene Coca-Cola
Werbung für den deutschen Markt die
deutsche Witze Klischees und so weiter
bedient eigene Coca-Cola Werbung für UK
eigene Coca-Cola Werbung für jede andere
Region für all diese unterschiedlichen
Regionen gibt es unterschiedliche
Budgets und quasi nie gibt es ein
internationales Budget also einen Topf
aus dem man placement bei MR Beast in
vielen verschiedenen Sprachen buchen
könnte und das ist ein riesen Problem
für Mr Beast weil er so keine faere
Bezahlung für seine sehr große sehr
internationale Community bekommen kann
und hier kommen wir ins Spiel macht Mr
Beast jetzt also Werbung für unsere App
und seinen Creator Code können weltweit
alle Zuschauer bares Geld in den für
ihre Region wirklich relevanten Shops
sparen Mr Beast muss sich nicht den
megaauwand mit der Internationalisierung
für z.B fies machen und kann mit der
Erstellung eines einzelnen Accounts von
seiner internationalen Community über
unsere App profitieren wieso ich mr
Beast als Beispiel genannt habe nun ja
er hat genau dieses Problem und woher
ich das weiß von unserem persönlichen
Treffen mit seinem Team dazu aber in der
nächsten Folge mehr also vergesst nicht
den Kanal zu abonnieren wenn ihr das
nicht verpassen wollt noch mal als Fazit
das System ist win win win die jops sind
happy weil sie mehr Reichweite haben die
Creator haben eine erste wirklich gute
internationale
monetarisierungsmöglichkeit und die
Nutzer können bares Geld sparen und das
Beste das Tool ist kostenlos will das
jemand benutzen dann benutzt er es will
das jemand nicht benutzen dann benutzt
er es halt einfach nicht die Idee ist
super easy weiterzus Spinnen es müssen
ja nicht nur Creator sein die man
unterstützen kann meldet sich z.B der
WWF worüber wir sehr happy wären kann er
gerne einen Creator Code bekommen s dass
ihr durch das Sparen mit unserer App den
atenschutz unterstützt so oder seid ihr
ein Sportverein und wollt dass eure
Mitglieder in dem Moment wo sie eh schon
shoppen den Verein noch ein bisschen
unterstützen ist das alles möglich der
größte Witz ist aber war all das gerade
besprochene ist Basisfunktionalität die
sofort bei Release da ist und
funktioniert also international sind wir
noch nicht aber die Funktionalität ist
da wir haben aber und jetzt wird's
richtig krank eine Möglichkeit das ganze
auch in den offline handandel zu bringen
haben sie eine Paybackkarte nein
glücklicherweise nicht aber ein Tool um
das ganze System abzulösen muss man mal
schauen glücklicherweise hat das
Potenzial auch sofort ein Investor
verstanden oder mehrere Investoren aber
wir haben uns für einen entschieden
deswegen wir schon bevor die App
veröffentlicht ist mit deutlich mehr als
ein zwei oder 3 Millionen bewertet sind
wie es dazu gekommen ist erfahrt ihr im
nächsten Video a ja ich weiß dass einige
Leute von WCs zuschauen weil sich nach
dem ersten Video schon die ersten VCS
gemeldet haben worüber wir mega happy
sind ich weiß auch dass das hier ein
ziemlich ungewöhnlicher Weg für euch ist
wir freuen uns aber riesig von euch zu
hören und gemeinsam zu schauen was
möglich ist und euch in persönlichen
Gesprächen Potenziale aufzuzeigen und so
weiter E-Mails findet ihr meldet euch
gerne dann können wir darüber quatschen
ja und ansonsten tickt die Uhr am
Mittwoch kommt direkt das nächste Video
am darauffolgenden Sonntag kommt direkt
die App und ein weiteres Video und dann
schauen wir mal wie das alles wird in
den nächsten Folgen besprechen wir
weitere Finanzierung Investment Treffen
mit Mr Beast Team und so weiter also
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
dann sehen wir uns in den nächsten paar
Tagen wieder